non plus
l'inter
les questions sur un casting galiana et
daniel mon attention première question
qu'a montré agustin galiana à laurent
ruquier son étoile sa planète où
s'allume et toi tu vas salvat quoi salut
salut non alors c'est quoi étoiles
étoiles étoiles et toiles je dis non non
non je l'avais dit la vérité toute nue
s'il vous plaît il ya quelques semaines
dans les enfants de la télé vous avez
montré votre étoile
regardez moi moi comme cobayes je
m'apprête à auch avec ma belle soeur et
ça fait déjà douze ans que je lai non
voilà je crois
elle est extensive comprend la lune a
également testé m6 avait une étoile la
wii c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas vu dans
l'émission n'a pas bien vu on ne sera
pas complet apparemment matthew boudreau
vend son étoile d'un coût de 5 mathieu
ccl hamon avait à me voir les toiles et
les clones est ancienne
vous pouvez nous montre également uranus
et venez vite vous avez d'autres
tatouages
non j'étais très discrète pourquoi il me
dira comme ça ben c'est pas parce que
elle m'a dit je vais faire un truc
simple moi j'ai dit je vais je vais dans
un endroit où je vois rien et finalement
je vois pas bien où la mairie finalement
on a décidé en bas parce que vous croyez
moi tu vois je suis comédien j'ai pas
envie d'avoir comme un tatouage vous à
non c'est vrai j'aimerais vous faire
peut-être un tatouage
non j'ai un peu peur moi sinon des fêtes
a pas fait - délire gens même là on
branche sud et que je m'en prends
régions privées pour projet la même
étoile c'est christine me le demande
gentiment je verrai mon fils sur les
demandes et gentil est ce que tu
voudrais faire une étoile au cul
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je l'attendais pas de kiné bon ça que je
le fais c'est pour ça que je joue
beaucoup
tout ça j'ai dit au cul c'est tellement
méchant du 5 août et une blinde et des
laïcs comme vous l'a dit non mais c'est
vrai on est beaucoup dans la bouche des
rustines tout pas sa voiture fait une
bonne émission
elles vont bien le bouquin
[Rires]
les enfants de la radio daniel mots
entendus à nanning on adore souvenir des
grandes voix dans quel jeu télévisé
daniel moreau at-elle été candidate en
1984 où là aussi alors 3,4 à un jeu télé
non pas d'arrêter les jambes c'est quoi
si c'était quoi
jacques martin vrai nom le monde que
vous présentez par notre ami jean pierre
descombes sur france 3 vous tentiez de
faire de faire dire à une invitée un
adverbe ou un adjectif regarder ça c'est
parti et je veux rentrer dans ton
candide un petit 20 ans et qui a demandé
un adjectif prête madame vous allez
poser quelques questions à micheline dax
pour découvrir un adjectif c'est la
règle du jeu lent connais bien ce jeu
vous avez votre prénom et votre nom
daniel moreau alors d'alien vos
questions on encourage de noël et vous
jouez avec micheline enfants micheline
d'année alors d'abord êtes vous content
de vous retrouver en famille avec carel
hernandez pour les ans tu as raison tu
permets way judas raison je suis était
très contente
daniel monde
il n'avait pas changé c'est bien le
maire de paris c'était jacques chirac il
avait serré la main au moins trois fois
chacun je peux pour passer j'avais peur
j'ai un endroit vous avez des références
france 2 ça normalement ça sur ses
billets pour la coupe caf où vous êtes a
été mis notamment avec avec un peu de
dix ans de moins et 10 et son délire et
là attention vous avec un point on
espère bien son nom et pourtant
d'encaisser les espagnols at on pu voir
agustin galiana aux côtés de mire way
n'diaye lognos tel un diable qui a parlé
ouais tu as parlé et mois dégueulasses
je sais quoi elle va faire la photo non
[Applaudissements]
alors vous avez entendu
non non c'est le premier tour premier
tour et un temps tenu alors c'est quoi
windows reste août au stress et gâteaux
également c'est que vous avez un petit
rôle dans une bosse très serait
évidemment un extrait de vous vous
jouiez lebon sébastien ouais c'est vrai
regardez comme il est beau et que tu
travailles avec la tienne de moto elle
sera morte avant que tu les as livre
était similaire aux deux poulets moi
j'aurais pas d'accident et on verra dit
donc est ce que tu peux m'expliquer
pourquoi chaque fois tu enlèves contexte
c'est pour faire une place à ta copine
ah ouais elle aime pas trop se sentir à
l'étroit surtout pour coller son petit
cul derrière le mien qui se passe et
bastien tu vois bien c'est mauvais pour
ce que tu as et évite le trampoline
[Applaudissements]
préfère comme ça alors pour l'instant
vous avez deux points je rappelle qu'il
ya cinq questions il faut avoir trois
points qui s'est fait pécho par daniel
moreau dans touche pas à mon poste
thierry moreau aymeric bonnery ou cyril
hanouna roll up ou les 3l a coûté les
trois vallées trop suis alors allé
thierry moreau thierry moreau regardez
la réponse en images
[Musique]
daniel daniel c'est moi je veux te paie
chaussée
je suis trop petit c'est dommage
francine gagnon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais c'est fou sens une vraie chaudière
pas du doigt les ailes et on s'est tous
dit c'est vrai c'est évident c'est un
dans le cadre d'un jeu nous rappelle
qu'un jeu est un jeu pouvoir avec
attention
mecheri jean michel maire vous avez deux
points seraient jouées sur cette
question qu'à vendus
vendu à la baule à augustine guardian
adam à faire conclut l'émission de
sophie davant sur france 2 suivi et a
vendu un truc aller bah allez allez y a
pas de combat des gens malheureusement
non à oui si tu l'as vu je pense
peut-être à des chaussures des
chaussures quelques chaussures de danse
pas des chaussures des chaussures et par
louis des chaussures de bilan ce passing
chaussures tu vas bien vous avez
participé à faire conclure il ya
quelques semaines on ne s'attendait pas
du tout à vous voir et vous êtes venus
je vous le dis pour vendre ça ça des
bases et base des vases on à l'extrémité
mal de danse et regardez on va vous avez
improviser une chanson
regardez mon gars que je te propose
il faut que tu es beaucoup d'imagination
il faut que tu glisses
alexandra et julien dans ta chanson et
eu à 700 euros points on se croise au
hasard alexandra tu vas bien dis moi
comment vas-tu julien
c'est pas mal mais j'ai bientôt
remarquable et voilà c'était des bases
dont jean michel maire vous l'avez
retrouvé shopzilla dans un instant